love you two on the Real Love Boat how
long have you been wanting to work on a
project together
you know we have worked together before
but this was completely different
because we were not only working
together we were
on a cruise together we were we
literally never separated for 22 days it
was beautiful
it was beautiful I was standing next to
him it was working all day long and then
but it's amazing
back to our little room and it was about
our one bed okay it was fun it was
there's no break and it was beautiful
it was wonderful well you know what's so
funny is Jerry and I you haven't said it
was amazing
that's real love we have worked together
in so many different projects that will
be first started dating like when we
were still secret dating I got up one
morning and said
I think we're I'm just starting uh I was
doing a small independent movie and he I
found out later that day was on the same
movie at a smaller part though I was
like a background no but like hey people
like crossover projects since the very
first met I mean it's um but this was
our this is like the most amount of time
at work together by far we've ever spent
and it was beautiful it was really
magical
97
Buick
197
incredible I love it okay so Rebecca
co-workers we're television hosts
we're lovers okay
okay
subjects we're professional yes we are
a real love poet
I love that okay Rebecca for the three
percent that it wasn't beautiful and
perfect yeah what happened there did you
get each other's nerves Gary forgets
um that we work together and he thinks
that he can tell me what to do while at
work oh oh
in charge and that's where I'm like
excuse me I'm so sorry
it was my bad I have apologized I am
currently in therapy and I said I'm
sorry and I take responsibility I want
to make amends right here on ET Canada
and say I am sorry I am not your boss I
am your uh husband and not your boss yes
there we go you know I have to do a
bingo ball thing where we like pull out
names and that's what we do in our Sail
Away ceremonies and you were telling me
to do it faster and I was sad I'm doing
it as fast as I can whatever listen
we're gonna try and stay married to the
end of this interview okay please
I love it
um how emotionally invested do you get
with the sail away ceremonies do you get
nervous
um yeah yes Jerry you know more avid
fans of this type of reality dating show
and so to get to host one was a real
dream come true but Jerry often forgot
that he is the host he thought he was
still sitting at home on his sofa
watching the show and would get too
emotionally invested Jerry tended to
have real big reactions if somebody
would get eliminated or if somebody
chose somebody unexpected Jerry go
just be Switzerland you know um it was
very difficult for Jerry to pull back I
dare to say the most difficult thing for
me and I don't know if Rebecca felt the
same thing is when the relationships
start to form and we're right there
right now like really like we're
starting to see some real relationships
happen we are and
the producers
they would want me to get in depth about
their relationships specifically one
relationship which they may or may not
have just been doing it to get to the
prize at the end like they made a little
bit of a pact which and
I I had to ask them pretty personal
questions and I was a little
uncomfortable at first but then as the
episodes went on I was like hey what's
going on here really
um really getting like quite personal
but um hey I do have to shout out wait
look just fix my camera here
we do have to shout out Canada we have
so many Canadians on the real love oh
Windsor Ontario on Calgary and uh and
Toronto Ontario go really far in our
show yeah Canada is well represented
there are
there are three Canadians three
Canadians who go super far we actually
spent a lot of time talking about our
neighborhoods that we live in include
myself included because my wife we live
in Canada half a year working on the
strange new world so yeah like they're
in Ontario
so uh go Argos yeah yes that's amazing
okay so I want to know if you were both
on this show who would be better at
doing the challenges
oh you know what's so funny is every
challenge that we host and the
challenges are great on the real
lookbook they're a lot like The Amazing
Race and those challenges or Survivor
which are just so good at those
challenges
um every time we would watch one and
have to host it Rebecca and I would be
like and we want to do this challenge so
bad we would win it there was one that
involved kayaks and Diving and stuff
that's so beautiful when we go to Greece
it's an incredible It Blow I'm sorry I
love my Amazing Race and I love my
Survivor it blows any of those
challenges out of the water pun intended
um because it's a puzzle and it's an
underwater puzzle and it's crazy and
it's physical it's a physical race it's
a balance there's like some math it's
got all of it we really thought like we
always had a little bit of an aside to
each other about how well we would do if
we had that challenge and then there was
like one or two challenges which is
logistically I was like no we wouldn't
win that one
because
like there was one where um uh the
couples had to be very honest with each
other about like
transgressions in the past and just yeah
how many people right right and um
I I would have been I would have never
been changed my way through that yeah
this is turning into like a like a
therapy session
I love this so much wait did you really
getting real here did you both recently
in July celebrate your 15th wedding
anniversary yes well champagne
oh she's like expensive stuff I'm sure
I'm sure you get asked this all the time
but you both look like you have so much
fun together is that the key to this
relationship yes it is I think you
always have to look for what's funny I
think it's also really important you
know as I said sometimes Jerry I love
Jerry Jerry makes me very happy but also
sometimes Jerry makes me mad
but I think that the key to a long
relationship is figuring out how to
bounce back from fights easily and I
think we've learned how to do that over
the years is Jerry's very good at um
defusing me when I'm mad and also we
don't like to ruin our days together
especially if we're doing something fun
so yeah we've become very good at our
fight recovery we're able to recover
from a fight like that like really
quickly that's true
pipe recoverers
I love that we're recovering Fighters
wait what it works I totally get it okay
I like this Jerry has said that Rebecca
he wants you on the Real Housewives of
Beverly Hills what do you think about
that
I it would be hard for me I would rather
gossip about them than be one of them I
feel like if I was on the show and I
gossiped about them that would lead to
fighting and I'm not I'm not interested
in fighting with them I um I'd rather
talk about them not be one of them I was
uh I gotta tell you I was really on for
it and I went to Bravo con this last
weekend which was so much fun I highly
suggest
everybody go to it every year it was
such a fun time but I hosted a couple
panels but it was just such a fun energy
in the building but um they had the
panel for Real Housewives of Beverly
Hills and Lisa Renault who was one of
our favorites uh got booed and
um it really like kind of it was like it
was a little too real for me you know
what I'm saying and Lisa took it in
stride it was super funny and
it gave the whole crowd the finger and
it was sort of I mean I thought it was
entertaining it was like modern day
wrestlers like wrestlers like WWE from
the 80s but women they're like beautiful
wrestlers getting booed by thousands of
people at Comic-Con and then giving him
the fingers
Rebecca on a scale of one to ten how
much game did Jerry have when you first
met
terrible game Jerry is I mean 12 15 25
130 77 11. I seriously like so much
Jerry's got gay like Jerry can come up
and say the perfect funniest thing in
the whole world that will get your
attention it's the skill it's a skill I
love this okay and just as I wrap this
up I'm learning so much about you too I
love you both even more now um who came
up with the idea to sing the theme song
in the opening credits well we couldn't
stop singing the theme song while we
were shooting the show I mean yeah and
our kids too like everybody we were all
just because it's an amazing theme song
and also we watched the original series
uh when it was in reruns in the in the
80s so it's there's a very there's a
Nostalgia to the real look to the
original Love Boat that we were
embracing with the Real Love Boat it's
really about people looking for a second
chance at love I love to hear it you two
are my favorite congratulations I want
you to host every show now because you
are so much fun together thank you